[Music]
brittany's in connecticut hey brittany
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave it's nice to talk to you guys
today you too how can we i just have
um i have a fairly general question but
with like
intricate details i guess um my question
more or less is
what more can i do um my husband and i
on baby step two we actually bought a
house
in march and then started your program
and in april he left for a six-month
training in virginia
um so we're putting everything
extra that we can towards our desk we've
paid off about
seventeen thousand so far um
he does and he does full time down there
so he gets like a per diem and
everything
um i work two part-time jobs adding up
to about fifteen dollars an hour and i
run a
very small business out of our home and
i have a i take care of a two-year-old
at home
um and i just don't know what more i can
do to help towards it
i feel like he's doing so much and he's
away um
i get to see him once or twice a month
at the at the moment
but um just any advice on what more we
can do i guess
so brittany how much what's your total
amount of debt
uh total was 25 000. we paid about
13 off so far that's the seventh one
since when since a
march end of march y'all are grinding we
phone everything we can
um well at that rate at that rate you'll
be done in three months
yeah the whole thing um
well no i'm talking about mathematically
it's not hoping oh yeah
well we had like the um anything we got
back from
uh taxes and stuff so how much are you
paying on the debt a month
about three thousand oh three thousand
you're not gonna be done in three months
now okay
no more like more like eight months okay
yeah but if we like anything extra he
makes during
dash or i make with my little side stuff
and we try to sew towards it so let me
let me say this on an
encouraging side britney because i hear
the passion in your heart like
i want to help more i want to help more
this is what we teach here at ramsey is
be intentional
get a plan live below your means and
throw everything at it
and if you're doing those four things
which it sounds like we could dive in a
little bit deeper to see what else you
could do
but i really want you to hear this and
even everyone listening as well
that once you're doing all those four
things the next step from there is just
keep that going and be patient
throughout this journey
putting three thousand dollars towards
this debt you all are already doing
great you've knocked out 13
13 or 17 whichever one uh that that you
did
um that that's phenomenal i mean that's
phenomenal
people who make more money than you call
into the show and don't knock out that
much money
uh within that amount of time so i want
you to hear that what you and your
husband doing right now
is great you know but can we add some
more
we can dive into some numbers and see
that there but i just wanted to start
off this this conversation by hey
you're doing a great job thus far uh but
let's see what else we can do
yeah the you got the hustle part now you
got the next step is the grind part
and you're feeling you're feeling the
grind because this is hard yeah we're
just
trying we look forward to the day we can
come to our debt-free scream
but i mean you guys are working like
animals yeah you're not spending a dime
you're completely game on you're as
gazelle intense as you can be
it's hard what you're doing is hard and
it is a grind that's why they call it
hustle and grind right i mean it's
it's hard so i'm with anthony i think
you're doing a really really good job
and i think in the seven or eight months
you're going to be done
so all you're looking for all the time
there's no magic
wand there's no magic pill you're just
looking for where can i cut expenses
where can i increase income
where can i cut expenses where can i
increase income and every time you do
that by five dollars
one direction or the other that five
dollars is going to increase the speed
at which
you get out of debt and now that you've
stopped the stupid and now that you've
pointed yourself
at a plan and now that you're submitted
to that plan and you're
wide open on that plan you're going to
get there
you are on your way you're going to get
there and you're probably going to be
there by christmas of this year
you may not quite make it but i think
you might i think you might be done by
christmas
can you be standing out in the front
yard yelling merry christmas
[Music]
people be going that woman lost her mind
no she's debt free baby
exactly she's been hustling she's been
grinding she hadn't lost her mind at all
the rest of you people have lost your
minds